alexis petri und sein sohn noah am gehen
mindestens einmal die woche in die
synagoge
sie leben nicht streng religiös sagen
sie aber ihr glaube sei ihnen sehr
wichtig
normalerweise bieten sie hier nicht
allein aber in der korona zeit ist auch
hier alles anders
die westend synagoge in frankfurt ist
eine der wenigen die während der
pandemie offen hat weil sie groß genug
ist um abstände einhalten zu können
so wichtig ihr glaube ihnen ist alexis
und noah legen die krippe ab sobald sie
die synagoge verlassen haben
[Musik]
weil ich schon selbst der u-bahn
beleidigung komische blicke oder teils
körperliche angriffe miterlebt habe es
trifft ein überall wenn man sich
öffentlich als jude bekennt und das ist
halt das große problem dann macht das
eine nicht nur traurig sondern man fragt
sich dann auch ob man fremd im eigenen
land geworden ist und das ist schlimm
und das bedrückt 1
alexis petri und seine frau esther die
israelin ist haben vier kinder
noah die zwillinge rolle und dann 15
jahre alt und die achtjährige lea
selbst als die jungs noch kleiner waren
haben sie schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
wenn sie als juden zu erkennen waren
alle drei spielen beim jüdischen
fußballverein makkabi frankfurt
ganz klar trage ich die täter draußen
also ich tu dir immer ins t shirt rein
da ich weiß dass ich sonst verbal oder
physisch angegriffen werden könnte ich
habe auch schon ein paar verbale
angreifen erlebt immer wenn ich zum
beispiel mit man mag abi t shirt
rausgegangen bin da wurde immer so
scheiß juden hätte man euch doch alle
vergast [ __ ] gerufen ich kenne
die situation schon seit langem also ich
bin halt immer noch so sehr geschockt
davon aber ich weiß dass solche vorfälle
immer wieder passieren nur weil jubeln
und das finde ich halte es traurige
jetzt
ist das und alex dass großeltern wurden
von den nazis ins konzentrationslager
deportiert
sie sind besorgt weil sie wissen dass
der holocaust damals in deutschland auch
mit hetze und beschimpfungen gegen juden
begangen die leute haben halt immer
mitgemacht und die frage ist
wo musst du eine du musst die eine
grenze ist und wo ist die grenze dann
merkst du dass es von unbedachten worten
bzw vielleicht auch aggressiven worten
wo ist deine grenzen gute sagt jetzt
sehe ich der weg ist falsch
antisemitische erfahrungen machen die
spieler von makkabi frankfurt auch auf
dem fußballplatz hier darf jeder
mitglied sein unabhängig von
nationalität und religion es ist aber
ein jüdischer fußballverein und deswegen
sagt der trainer würden seine jungs oft
beschimpft und beleidigt
als jude verpiss dich verpiss dich aus
frankfurt makkawi hat hier nichts zu
suchen und da kommt dann schon während
des spiels kommentare zu den
gegenspielern nach dem spiel lautes
gebrüll hatten wir auch schon scheiß
jugendverein nach einer niederlage oder
so wo wir dann auch mehrmals mit dem
kind mit den eltern sprechen mussten und
ich mich jedes mal frage wie tief
verankert ist es wirklich wie tief ist
es bei den eltern auch mal die müssen es
ja den kindern weitergeben es kommt kein
9 oder 10 jährige auf die idee auf
einmal antisemitische kommentare
abzulassen der 20 jährige konrad ist
nicht nur trainer hier sondern spielt
selbst bei makkabi ii in der ersten
mannschaft
ist kein jude er erlebt trotzdem immer
wieder antisemitische beleidigungen
scheiß jude und es wird neben ein
gespuckt das schockiert ein als als
spieler der mannschaft und ich sagen
würde ich habe angst aber letztens habe
ich meinem akw auf den fahrern
ausgezogen weil ich mich einfach nicht
wohlgefühlt ab und findet es schade weil
ich das ja selbst mit der leber wohl ich
nicht wie ich bin dass hier eine gewisse
angst lebe die an veränderungen gegen
die spieler von makkabi frankfurt kommen
sowohl von gegnerischen spielern als
auch von zuschauern sagt der präsident
von maka bialon meyer er weist seit
jahren darauf hin und zeigt dass auch an
sport schiedsgerichts gibt es immer
wieder verfahren
überwiegende teil an anfeindungen kommen
eben von gegnern und muslimische
arabisch hintergrund das ist nun mal so
und das beginnt mit scheuch hat man
vergessen zu vergasen bis sie den juden
trikot aus und dann auch
handgreiflichkeiten direkt nach dem
spiel oder bis hin zu messerattacken
auch das habe schon gespürt die meisten
angriffe gegen makkabi spieler also
durch muslime wir wollten mit den
mannschaften sprechen die antisemitisch
aufgefallen waren doch zu einem
interview waren sie nicht bereit
anders als die jungen spieler vom sg
brown in der jugendabteilung sind die
meisten hier muslime zwischen 15 und 16
jahre alt
wo ist in deutschland geboren seine
eltern kommen aus afghanistan mit
antisemitismus will er nichts zu tun
haben
wenn so etwas passiert dann ist es halt
auch so eine sache wie die eltern die
kinder erziehe ich meine ich wurde so
erzogen dass man jeden menschen
akzeptieren sollte
und ja ich bin halt auch immer geld auch
immer in die moschee und da wird uns
auch beigebracht dass wir einen menschen
nicht anders beurteilen soll nur weil er
jetzt eine andere religionen hat ob er
jude ist oder christ auch die anderen
hier sehen das so
ich finde es einmal nicht gut man sollte
jeden respektieren und muss man hat wie
gesagt nichts damit zu tun aber mit dem
hintergrund in deutschland ist ziemlich
wieder ich sagen
schlecht das mag aber jetzt als verein
ganze zeit beleidigte eingriffen wird
weil es macht keinen sinn den eindrücken
zu beschuldigen kriegen seine hautfarbe
oder wegen seiner herkunft oder wegen
seiner religion
auch einige spieler vom sg praunheim
erleben immer wieder rassismus
mein teamkamerad
deshalb dunkelhäutigen er wird mal
mit dem schimpfwort beleidigt und
ja man kann sagen er ist ein
anschließend aber ausgang aus dem feld
wollte weiterspielen
der 15 jährige imran hat einmal bei
einem punkte spiel von makkabi frankfurt
zugeschaut und war entsetzt das auf
einem auch zum schauer angefangen haben
und welche ausdrücke gegenüber den
spielern zu geben zb
sowas auch angegriffen worden nach dem
spiel das zu streitereien kam dass auch
körperlich angegriffen wurde und das
geht so was nicht
[Musik]
körperlich angegriffen wurden auch schon
die söhne von familie petri als sie
einmal im park fußball spielten kamen
sie mit jugendlichen ins gespräch die
sie nach ihrem verein fragten damals
seien sie klein gewesen sagen sie und
hätten keine bedenken gehabt makkabi
frankfurt zu antworten
und wir haben gar nicht verstanden warum
wir angesetzt worden und
dann haben wir gesagt wir wollen nach
hause gehen dann kam halt erstmal die
verbalen rufe ich als jude und dann
wurden wir dann abgeworfen wir hatten
sehr genau seit dem tag ziehen auch
keine batterie sachen er draußen nach
habe ich damit meine eltern darüber
geredet was man in diesen situationen
machen kann aber ich bin gar nicht auf
die situation klar gekommen weil es war
meine erste große physische
erfahrung als dass man mich angegriffen
hat nur weil jude rückten
auch nina macht sich auch sorgen um ihre
kinder
die jüdin ist alleine
ihr sohn luke spielt auch bei makkabi
frankfurt fußball der achtjährige darf
sein vereins pulli mit dem davidstern
nur tragen wenn ihnen jemand zum
training oder zum spiel fahren kann mit
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln haben sie
sehr schlechte erfahrungen gemacht
haben das damals schon vor jahren schon
erlebt ist wenn die mit magie im
kleidung in der u-bahn waren es hier
einfach sprüche bekommen haben und
scheiß juden solche dinge die haben
gerade oft erlebt wenn wir mit der bahn
fahren oder beim fahrradfahren fühle ich
mich dabei nicht so sicher ich muss
sagen es gibt mittlerweile für uns juden
hier in deutschland leider so no go
gegenden wo ich auch wirklich mit den
kindern durchlaufe und einfach merke
mich selber erwischt wie ich direkt
gewählt nämlich demokratie jacke mit aus
dem auto also das passiert mir oft
der 18-jährige lennox und sein älterer
bruder luis sagen dass sie
antisemitismus auch von deutschen
erleben
viele würden es noch nicht einmal merken
zum beispiel da sagt einer ja irgendwie
dreimal klopfen dass keine juden am
tisch sind in einem lokal in frankfurt
so und natürlich sage ich dann was und
dann kommt immer die reaktion
entschuldigung ich wusste ja gar nicht
dass die jüdisch bist als ob es okay
gewesen wäre wenn ich nicht an dem tisch
gesessen hätte oder wenn ich leuten
gesagt habe dass viele spender es sich
so eine reaktion bekommen habt wie echt
das hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht
dass du jüdisch bist so mit den subtexte
du bist ja ein total cooler typ und ich
hätte dich jetzt gar nicht so
eingeschätzt du einer von diesen juden
bis von diesen exotischen menschen so
beim fc maroc der in frankfurt in der
kreis oberliga spielt ist der trainer
auch linken
woche obermann hat 20 jahre lang
mannschaften von makkabi frankfurt
trainiert bis er vor ein paar jahren
wechselte
beim fc maroc sind fast alle spieler und
auch der vorstand muslime
sie alle beschäftigt die gewalt im nahen
osten
natürlich beeinflusst 1 muslim oder ein
was da passiert wenn man sieht hier
seine seine glaubensbrüder werden da
mehr oder weniger im fernsehen
abgeschlachtet dann passieren so dinger
und es ist ein leute die halt teilweise
das nur von den medien mitbekommen und
sich nicht mehr gedanken machen die
tiefe gehen aber es ist richtig die
juden dafür verantwortlich zu machen
allgemein als das hat gar keinen fall
richtigen gibt viele leute die denken
die alle juden ist
dass israel und alle israel ist jude
aber das ist wahrlich und gibt viele
leute wissen das auch juden ist juden
dass eine religion der regierung wie
eben christian wie muslimen ihr habt ihr
alle und wir haben respekt vor der
religion aber
man fühlt sich in dieser mannschaft voll
respektiert ihm ist es wichtig zu
betonen dass die anfeindungen die er
damals als makabi trainer lebte von
mehreren seiten kam
die laufen aber nicht nur von
mannschaften die muslimische religion
zugehörigkeit sind sondern das habe ich
auf jeden bei deutschen verein gesehen
das habe ich da öfters erlebt sogar dass
man gesagt hat ich habe sie vergessen zu
vergasen auf einem in reinem deutsch das
habe ich viel mehr viel öfters gehört
als irgend einer beleidigung von der
muslimischen spiele und es gab natürlich
auch im jugendbereich spiele auch bei
deutschen gegen die jugendmannschaften
zwölf- bis 14-jährige sich einschließen
muss in der kabine und die position nur
unter polizeischutz raus konnten und und
und also es gab schon sehr häufig als im
jugendbereich ganz schlimm
bei den senioren kämen solche vorfälle
grundsätzlich weniger vor auch die
spieler vom fc maroc haben den
antisemitismus auf den demos in den
letzten wochen mitbekommen
wenn die demonstrative
christine rechte für palästina und
aufhören zum krieg bin ich dass sein
verstand aber dass da auch an die juden
greife an synagogen greifen das hat er
damit der nichts zu tun es ist ja
legitim irgendein regime oder irgendeine
regierung zu kritisieren wir sind ja in
einer demokratie hier freie
meinungsäußerung aber
pauschal eine religionsgemeinschaft
dafür verantwortlich zu machen was
beispielsweise jetzt in palästina
passiert ist ganz klar antisemitismus ja
alltags antisemitismus daran hätten sie
sich gewöhnt sagen nina und ihre familie
und sie sei nicht überrascht über die
judenfeindlichen demos in den letzten
wochen
die juden anstatt irgendwie jetzt
israelis und das ist schon beängstigend
ich finde jeder sollte jede politik so
wie weit er will kritisieren können es
wird nur eben dann problematisch wo das
existenzrecht israels irgendwie
grundsätzlich einfach aberkannt wird
auch familie petri machen solche
einstellungen sorgen der hass gegen
juden sei immer da gewesen sagen esther
und alexis dennoch sind sie manchmal
fassungslos
die letzte demonstration in hamburg die
hat mich wirklich schockiert
[Musik]
und genommen paramilitärische kräfte die
nicht bewaffnet sind aber die hasch und
paramilitärisch auftreten extrem
hasserfüllte
parolen schreien mitten in deutschland
in einer großen stadt hamburg die früher
auch immer der welt offenbar und da ist
keiner eingeschritten
eine gruppierung namens muslim
interaktiv bei ende mai der veranstalter
so sehr
schlachtrufe die zur vertreibung der
juden aus israel aufrufen
es waren szenen die auch die jüdische
gemeinde schockierten
benjamin graumann kritisierte aber auch
dass man in deutschland offiziell mit
organisationen zusammenarbeitet die sich
antisemitisch zeigen wie der türkisch
muslimische dachverband bietet die tüv
untersteht der türkischen
religionsbehörde diyanet kontrolliert
von stadtpräsident erdogan diyanet hatte
nach den jüngsten militärischen
eskalationen israel als baby mörder
bezeichnet gerade hat
nordrhein-westfalen beschlossen die tib
wieder im islamischen schulunterricht zu
beteiligen das sei das falsche signal
weil gerade bietet in den letzten jahren
immer wieder aufgefangen ist durch
antisemitische äußerungen durch
holocaust relativierende äußerungen und
so ein so einer gesellschaft die ja auch
eine tochter organisation der diyanet
ist das sprachrohr von herrn erdogan der
durch diese organisation hass und
antisemitismus verbreitet kann nicht der
richtige partner sein wenn es darum geht
aufklärung bei schülern und schülerinnen
zu betreiben
[Applaus]
hass und antisemitismus
das erlebt man auch immer wieder auf pro
palästinensischen demonstrationen
israel existiert nicht steht auf diesem
plakat alles ist palästina
auch am samstag gab es wieder eine
demonstration bei strömendem regen in
frankfurt am main
sie hätten nichts gegen juden hören die
hier von vielen aber gleichzeitig auch
solches los
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der river to the sea gemeint ist das
gebiet vom jordan bis zum mittelmeer und
damit üblicherweise auch die zerstörung
des staates israel
ganze familie ausgelöscht wurden wir
denken gleichzeitig an alle anderen tun
wir fragen nach bei der hauptrednerin
der demonstration
erkennen sie an dass es israel gibt das
israel geben muss neben palästina
ergebnis nicht anzuerkennen sondern es
ist eine realität dass es die
besatzungsmacht gibt die besatzungsmacht
ist da und zwar voller gewalt mit
militärmacht mit allem drum und dran
erkennen sie das existenzrecht israels
an apartheid regime israel ist ein
rassistisches kolonialistische
system der zionismus ist eine
rassistische ideologie von anfang an
gewesen was würde das moralisch bedeuten
wenn ich sage ja es hat existenzrecht
die zionisten was sie wollen die bein
und die wollen uns wirklich ermorden das
ist rassismus was die machen aber ist
nicht auch rassismus man ihn dann sagt
mit gegenzug israel hat kein
existenzrecht aber was woraus wurde es
wie so existiert israel was war vorher
da menschen meinen tag es war kein
leeres land also keine
zwei-staaten-lösung das würde nicht
funktionieren
es ist ein existenzrecht beruht darauf
dass sie von dissidenten
und jetzt ist meine frage auch an die
leute diese fragen sind sie dafür dass
die koalition ente ermordet werden wir
hören aber auch andere töne
die lösung werde wenn die zionisten sich
endlich mit den palästinensern zusammen
vereinigen und für die freiheit streben
und für ein friedliches zusammenleben
aber solange sie die palästinenser aus
deren häusern raus schmeißen wird gibt
es keine lösung dann könnten sie zwei
staaten
wir brauchen wir brauchen regierungen
die die ihn nicht auf nationalistische
art und anwalts papieren von regierungen
menschen miteinander zusammenleben und
ich bin froh dass man ihr hund weg ist
es steht auf dieser demonstration haben
wie er radikale und wenig versöhnliche
töne gehört
und mit diesem plakat wurde vorher für
die demo geworben ganz israel ist
palästinensisches gebiet
bei dem letzten pro-palästinensischen
protest in frankfurt mitte mai kam es
zum großen vor der westend synagoge
die polizei twitterte dass sich eine
personengruppe zielstrebig in richtung
der synagoge bewegt hatte
dutzende polizeiwagen und beamte rückten
an um das jüdische gotteshaus zu sichern
das synagogen in deutschland immer hoch
gesichert sind und unter polizeischutz
stehen daran haben sich viele juden in
deutschland schon lange gewöhnt
genauso wie daran dass sie
antisemitismus alltäglich erleben
du nicht mehr wächst und die leute sind
hemmungsloser diesen gewaltbereiter und
das macht mich traurig aber dem müssen
wir entschieden entgegentreten weil wir
eines aus unserer vergangenheit gelernt
haben eben nicht wegzuschauen was viel
zu viele hier viel zu lange gemacht
haben wir brauchen nicht nur
sonntagsreden von politikern sondern wir
brauchen taten das ist einmal ein
entschlossenes und entschiedenes
vorgehen gegen antisemitismus den
antisemitismus ist am ende ja nicht nur
ein angriff auf uns juden sondern
angriff auf unsere freien werte und auf
unsere demokratische gesellschaft
realität in deutschland ist dass sich
viele juden hier nicht sicher fühlen wie
lennox der darüber nachdenkt nach israel
auszuwandern
ich will das eigentlich nicht weil ich
mich eigentlich auch deutsch fühlen und
hier gerne wohne und ich will hier
eigentlich nicht weg aber natürlich muss
man sich in irgendeiner art und weise
damit beschäftigen
nina sagt dass sie sich mehr solidarität
und mehr schutz wünschen würde wenn ich
jetzt über die sicherheit sprechen bin
ich eigentlich streams enttäuscht von
unserer sag ich jetzt mal guten
deutschen gesellschaft da fühle ich mich
extrem ist ungeschützt und da wünsche
ich mir einfach viel mehr solidarität
für uns juden dass wir hier in
sicherheit leben können auf familie
petri sieht das so
man kann auch sagen sollte sich die
situation verschärfen dann ist es eine
flucht also das thema der flucht aus der
heimat ist wieder präsent das ist leider
so
jude in deutschland zu sein bedeutet für
viele nicht nur oft gefährlich zu leben
sondern sich auch fremd zu fühlen im
eigenen land
[Musik]